let's go to a caller from the four one
three area code love seeing four one
three Western Massachusetts caller from
four one three what's going on hey how's
it going David good how are you not too
bad I'm just calling regarding a topic
that you briefly touched on before but
you didn't really have a chance to
expand one at a time okay you were
talking about legalization of drugs and
you're mostly for it but you had some
reservations I personally have always
kind of sort of been of the mindset all
drugs should be legal as long as they're
not as long as you're not able to sell
it to minors you're not hurting anyone
but it sound like you had some
reservations I was kind of curious what
your reservations about legalizing so my
reservations are merely I mean so here's
basically my thought I want to
decriminalize all drugs for sure I want
to legalize many of them I just am
unsure about the net effect of
legalizing black tar heroin for
recreational use I'm just not sure about
that I've not I've heard good arguments
for and against so I'm clear on
decriminalization I'm clear on
legalization of many drugs just on the
the recreational legalization of cocaine
and heroin and stuff like that I'm just
unsure about but outside of I understand
understand but outside of the the
effects that drugs can have on someone
and the potentially dangerous behaviors
that they can partake in such as for
example driving under the influence
which is already illegal right or
assaulting someone or whatever like this
these are behaviors that make the
implant but those behaviors are already
illegal right so they are here's what my
here here's what my concern would be
with some of these drugs the at in any
dose they are so destructive to the
individual that it's hard for me to
imagine them not becoming destructive to
society so if you say listen someone's
gonna smoke pot in their house they're
not going to drive it's illegal to do
that anyway it's very clear that people
can smoke pot or have edibles or
ever in a way that is not going to have
a broader negative effect on society
something like heroin for example I just
don't know if it's use is truly just
limited to the individual who's choosing
to use it and that's it I don't know how
if you have children there's any way you
can just use heroin and it not affect
children I don't know if you have a job
if there's any way that you can use
heroin and have it not affect the people
you work with and whoever the customers
are of the business that's where I get
hung up on recreational legalization of
some of the the harder drugs
and I'm willing to have my mind changed
for sure okay all right I mean I still
don't totally agree but uh I definitely
don't have the time to go back and forth
but I definitely appreciate your take on
it all right were you calling from by
the way oh yeah actually I am calling
from Connecticut I was originally in
Springfield Mass all right very good
all right very good always in the four
one three area code thank you so much